okay so just a very brief reminder what
is secure and peace in case you weren't
listening to then Daniel so this was
introduced by yell go Dragoon Italian
witnessing and idea that we have an
mutually distrustful players we want to
jointly perform some computational tasks
together and by securely what I mean is
that an adversary that controls some
limited subset of the players learns
nothing more than the inputs and the
outputs of the players that it controls
and we can consider different types of
powers for the adversary and in this
talk I'm going to focus on the setting
of perfect information theoretic
security so no in contrast to Daniel's
talk no assumptions here and here we
have classical results of venerable
Vassar and Winterson and Chum crippled
and embarked from 88 and this is the
model where we have a synchronous
network and point of secure
point-to-point communication channels
between every two parties but the
adversaries completely is
computationally unbounded so we have
basic basically to classical results one
is with passive security which just
means that the adversary seize whatever
the players that it controls sees but it
can't they can't deviate from the
protocol and active security in which
the adversary can tell the player to
deviate arbitrarily from the protocol so
in the case of passive security we know
that every function or even every
functionality can be computed securely
in this passive setting as long as the
adversary controls strictly less than a
majority of the players and in the
active setting again every function of
functionality can be computed securely
if the adversary controls less than a
third even if the long as a dresser
controls less than a third of the
players so since these classical results
you have been a huge body of work on sku
computation but if you actually look at
the protocol if you want to understand
them or explain them to someone they're
fairly complicated what we tried to do
in this work is give a new and I think
conceptually appealing and simple
approach to designing secure protocols
and the basic technique that will use is
that of player emulation I'll explain
that and this builds on the work of here
in malware from 2000 but there are sort
of a very different motive
shin and in particular the results that
we get will be efficient protocols cure
by fission I just mean pulling on the
complexity I'm not claiming anything
more practical and this isn't but this
is in contrast to the result of here
tomorrow which is sort of more general
and inherently higher complexity so not
putting on the complexity in the number
of players okay so before I tell you how
this works let me just mention some
applications so first of all this allows
us to sort of reprove classical results
or variants of classical results such as
bgw in a way that I think is a
conceptual simple and appealing actually
the fact that this this approach turns
out to be very flexible so it's not very
hard wire to the model that you're
working in and this allows us to work in
sort of all kinds of other MPC models
that have been considered in the
literature in particular people have
been interested in the setting where all
the parties have sort of black book
access to some underlying algebraic
structure so if you think of bgw there's
sort of a field that everything is
working on people have considered rings
also a billion groups and this sort of
had Taylor different protocols for these
different models this approach turns out
to be very flexible and works also in
these models and we can actually improve
on the results on some of the results
and in these special models lastly we
can also directly get results for
distributed computing in the case of a
sort of Byzantine faults so we get
broadcast or Byzantine agreement
protocols directly and also there we can
sort of prove at least one thing that
was not previously known in the
literature remember I'm going to focus
on this part in the stock okay so trying
to reprove bgw okay so what's the idea
as I said it's going to be player
emulation what i mean by claire
emulation is so so really MPC gives us a
pc lets us securely evaluate a function
or functionality but you can think of a
player inside a protocol as realizing
some stateful or reactive functional
functionality and if we have a PC we can
replace its computational steps by by a
secure MPC protocol run by some other
players
yes for example if we have the displayer
that we aren't to ambulate it's supposed
to send a message we can use an MPC
protocol to emulate sending this message
using this idea what we're going to do
is to reduce this test of constructing
an MPC protocol for a large so and
players to that of constructing a
protocol for just a constant small
constant number of players which will
turn out to be just constructing the
protocol for a constant number of
players turns out to be easier will see
exactly why and just for the
presentation I'm going to focus first on
passive security and in this case I'll
show reduction from the task of
constructing an MPC protocol for end
players to that of constructing the
protocol for just three players the
reason for three is that sort of the
minimum number of players that you need
in order to get sort of non-trivial MPC
in the passive setting because the
adversary controls if you want to be a
non-trivial adversary controls one
player and then you need at least three
four together secure protocol so let's
see how this is done ok so again we're
assuming a 3 3 player MPC secure a
secure against one player and we want to
construct an FPC protocol for EM players
with passive security against they let
have strictly less than half of the
players ok so our starting point is
going to be the like the most trivial
protocol they can think of just involves
the trusted trusted the player so how
would you do the NPC if you have a
trusted player we have all of our of our
players send the input to the trusted
pair this guy computer output sends back
the results totally trivial
the idea is now is going to be to
emulate distrusted player by three other
sort of trusted players new virtual
players we want v2 and v3 so we have to
add new trusted players seem so it seems
like a not amazing idea but let's let's
see what happens so we have we have
these three new virtual players v1 v2
and v3 who are emulating whatever towel
did in the previous trivial protocol so
these guys were supposed to send a
message to tell will emulate this so we
have secure three party MP see this
tells us how to emulate sort of
receiving a message so these three guys
will receive the message in a secure way
they'll evaluate the function that house
opposed to now evaluate this function f
so the run a three-party the three party
on pc protocol that we assume in order
to do that and then again they'll
emulate sending back the results to all
the other parties okay so this seems to
be a little weird we replaced one
trusted party by three other by three
trusted parties oh doesn't seem amazing
but we did make progress actually
because in the original protocol it was
secure as long as the adversary sort of
didn't control the trusted party if you
think of the new protocol that we
constructed even if the adversary
controls say v1 or v2 or v3 but just
just like one of the these virtual
players the protocol will still be
secure because if you think of sort of
v1 v2 v3 running their secure three
party MPC protocol if just one of the
guys is corrupt we're still fine so we
didn't make some progress okay so even
if AB here controls one of these guys
we're still fine what we'll do now is
you know we made progress let's try to
make more progress let's try to emulate
v1 by three new virtual players w1 w2
and w3 so now the picture becomes more
complicated we the we have our real
players 1 2 3 4 & 5 we have virtual
players who are actually participating
in the protocol w1 w2 w3 v2 and v3 and
then we have sort of we just think of
them as players but they're not actual
players in the protocol v1 Intel so now
what's supposed to happen the real pairs
are supposed to send their inputs to
tell
okay that we already know we can emulate
between v1 v2 and v3 now in the
simulation v1 is supposed to do all
kinds of things will emulate that to
using w1 w2 and w3 so we have w1 w2 w3
emulating v1 and then v1 v2 and v3
emulating tell message doing
computations the computer is a little
baggy okay let's say I think when is
this protocol secure so say that only
say I don't know v1 say on the w1 w2 and
w3 are corrupt that sort of corresponds
to V 1 being corrupt in the previous
protocol which was fine on the other
hand even if say v2 is corrupt and w1 is
corrupt will still find that or it sort
of means that the one is honest and then
only v2 in a sense is corrupt out of the
v1 v2 and v3 and kind of the easier way
to see this is by considering the
following formula so we're going to have
a formula composed of three input
majority gates these sort sort of
corresponds to the fact that we need a
majority of the three players to be
honest the upper wire will correspond to
the dishonest player towel it's
connected and each get it sort of
connected to the three players that are
emulating the part the part of the is
above the gate okay so we have tau being
emulated by v1 v2 and v3 we have v1
being emulated by w1 w2 and w3 okay and
the next thing about viewing it this way
oops and I say about viewing is this way
so if you want to know if your protocols
that you against a particular adversary
place just place a 1 on the wires that
that correspond to players that
adversary controls and 0 on players that
it doesn't control and evaluate the
formula if you get in the upper wire 0
it means that the protocol is going to
be secure against at that adversary sure
the vertical you describe is secure
all of the w's are corrupt right yeah
yeah so that would be 1 1 100 then you
evaluate this guy is one these two are
zero you evaluate this thing and you get
a 0 sorry so uh right Sakura actually
even if all thing sorry so the direct
view the other formula okay so now how
do we proceed so let's imagine that
somehow we had a formula that's composed
only of these three input majority gates
and let's say that this formula computes
the majority function on n inputs the
formula is actually going to tell us how
to design the protocol how which players
are going to emulate which other players
so we'll just as before will associate
the root with a trusted trader tell and
each gate is going to be associated with
the virtual player and the virtual
player associated with the gate is
emulated by the three players underneath
then the bottom the input players are
just directly implemented by the real
players the input gates are implemented
by the real players okay so now as
before we can just associate ones and
zeros with the real players
corresponding to whether they're honest
or dishonest evaluate the formula I'm on
this input if in the end the Apple wire
has a zero that means that the protocol
secure against this this adversary that
controls this subset of the players
so since we assume that the formula
computes the majority function what
that's what this means is that our
protocol is secure as long as the
adversary doesn't control a majority of
the players which is exactly sort of a
bgw result that we wanted okay that's
great how about the complexity of this
thing we're doing a lot of recursions so
actually can think in each level each
each layer of the formula we're
replacing every single step made by a
virtual player by a constant number of
steps which are the three party on PC
protocol that is being read to emulate
that step so every layer we're paying a
constant multiplicative overhead so
overall will pay exponentially in the
depth and if you want to get an
efficient for an efficient protocol we
better have a logarithmic depth formula
yeah so this brings us to sort of two
missing ingredients that we still need
in order to get a secure npc the first
thing is so all we did is a reduction 23
party npc so we need a secure three
party protocol from somewhere and then
we also need this logarithmic depth
formula that computes the majority
function using only three input majority
gates so let's start with a secure three
party protocol that turned out to be
easy
first of all we could just use bgw
restricted to fill it to three players
that's already simpler than sort of the
full-fledged bgw but we can do better
than that so there's a beautiful
protocol by mauer called the npc made
simple it is indeed as stated very
simple it's major down down down side is
that you have to pay exponentially in
the number of players but here what we
did is we just need this protocol for
three player so exponential and three is
something that we're willing to deal
with games really shows you how reducing
from n parties to three parties I do
that you can make progress because you
can use protocols which in which the
dependency on the number of players can
be really large okay so that's how we
get our three party protocol okay how
about this formula so again we need a
logarithmic that formula computing the
majority function using only three input
majority gates and this is you know this
is a completely complexity theory at a
question I could could have asked you
this it doesn't seem directly related to
a multi-party computation anything too
we just thought that it is and in fact
it has interested complexity theorists
even back in the 80s so valiant in 84
gave a beautiful randomized construction
of such a formula basically the idea is
to take sort of a tree of like a
recursive majority tree and then while
you're in the inputs into this tree
totally at random enter that that with
extremely high probability over the
wiring this kind of formula will work
we'll just compute exactly the majority
function okay so we can use this
construction it has a downside though
because because this is a randomized
construction it means we're in the
passive setting so you can just have
sort of the first player choose the
random points for this construction but
with some very small probability will
choose bad coins in which case the
formula that we get doesn't evaluate the
majority function and then we're in
trouble so this will only get
statistical security so that's a
downside of this approach you have to
work a little bit harder and we gave
sort of a partial dear animas ation of
the valiance result this is based on
some interesting listed or randomized
techniques I won't have time to go over
but if you're interested I'd love to
tell you about about those and what we
got is a deterministic construction of a
log depth formula again only with only
these three input majority gates and it
almost computes the majority function it
works as long as you know let's say
fifty one percent of the inputs are on
the same side if if you're right in
between then you're in the problem
actually we can do much better than 51%
so if it's sort of one-half plus 2 to
the minus square root of log n fraction
of the players are on the same side then
we're also also okay if you could
improve this from 2 to the square root
of 2 to the minus square root of log on
to just 1 over N this would solve the
problem completely so we're pretty close
but not exactly there so this gives a
sort of an end party MPC protocol with
security as long as T is smaller than
this kind of value and then lastly we
can fully the randomized volume see
result but this is a conditional result
so assume under some assumptions for
example if there exist exponentially
strong one-way functions we can get a
fully randomization which is sort of a
curious situation in which under a
computational assumption we can get
information theoretic perfect security
so kind of a slightly strange situation
and actually we can use weaker the
atomization assumptions okay so these
are the three possibilities that we have
in the passive case this is a
conditional result so this was all about
the the passive setting what about
active security so if you look at
classical protocols bgw for example the
active setting is significantly more
complicated than the passive one it
turns out that in our case dr. setting
is not much more complicated it's almost
the same so the idea now be instead of
reducing from an end party protocol to
three party protocol will be to a
four-party protocol and for the same
reason as before because four is the
minimum number of players that you need
in order to get active security
okay and the idea now will be to sort of
again we'll have this kind of formula
every player will be emulated now by
four players but now we want at least we
want sort of at most one of the players
to be dishonest so instead of a majority
gate we want a threshold gate which is
sort of two out of four so if two or
more are dishonest then the guidance the
value if two or more of the MP wires are
correspond to dishonest players so they
have an value of one then the output
should be one that's a 12-4 threshold
gate so we just proceed as before
accepting now instead of this majority
out of majorities formula will the need
is a threshold out of thresholds of
constant size threshold gates and here
unfortunately if you try to do an analog
of values construction that doesn't give
you the correct kind of thing so what we
want here is to get out the one third
threshold function so it turns out not
to give you that however we did manage
to directly constructed deterministic
construction which as before it doesn't
exactly compute the one third function
but a very good approximation okay so
certainly for thirty two percent of the
guys are corrupt and we're fine again we
can do even less than a constant know
and I think it's interesting to give
either a like a non-uniform or
randomized construction here I think
would be interesting moral complexity
theoretic point of view ability of
gorgeous yeah we can do that too yeah
yeah can get that too yeah
okay so just to summarize what we
suggest is a new approach which i think
is uh conceptually appealing to
designing FPC protocols which works in a
really large variety of settings in
particular I didn't have time to talk
about it but it's considered things such
as an underlying of the break structure
such as a reg or an abelian group we can
get a few results there that even
improve upon our state of the art that
was known and then we have these sort of
scenic the independent complexity
throughout a question on which we made I
think a lot of progress but there's
still it's double open question which i
think is more interesting again from a
complexity point of view can you fully
the randomized that I've construction if
you're interested in that I can tell you
a little bit more offline so thank you
questions I would really like to see
something about the randomization
randomization okay so it seems your
result shows that the lower bound
something easy sitting business or bars
under the formula like you mean like the
complexity of uh if you have a lower
bound on the complexity of MPC protocols
yeah so you can't use for example using
only three input majority gates you
can't compute the forty percent sorry
about fifty five percent function yeah
but i think it was actually not oh
there's a characterization sort of a
similar creature characterization of
what kind of functions you can compute
only using this type of gate regardless
of the depth so it's called a cute so if
it's a majority gates it's called a q2
adversary structure basically means that
if you take any two vectors that
correspond to a one output and you look
at their or then they can't cover the
entire
yeah so in this reduced the majority
problem to activate majority problems
yeah atomic majority of protocols using
so is there a trade-off between
efficient efficiency you are going to
use a larger objects with this magnitude
more efficiently to list a protocol and
you can let try to handcraft a
particular good protocol for a small in
it so to reduce to a protocol for 100
employers actually it could I'm I
thought about it a little bit and it
doesn't seem that it would but I don't
see a reason why I inherited shouldn't
yeah you require you to you compute the
majority function with these three of
the majority yeah what if you don't
actually compute the majority but you
allow let's see some ways in which the
adversary could it could corrupt the
majority of the players to be secure so
in your example with five players yeah I
just find out every city could corrupt
three those yeah but it's still it's a
not any three over three hours yeah
right so with that formula does a big
majority but it still gives you what you
want right so that utilize the
requirement you actually yes so that's
like a well study thing in the
literature is called in a general
adversary structure so an adversary that
controls this party that party and that
party or only the party that so actually
the original paper of hidden power they
were interested in exactly this question
in constructing protocols for general
adversary structures and not not this
particular threshold one but they
obtained sort of inefficient protocols
if an efficient in the number of players
sort of point oh you silly structure
before so the construction is uh this
idea of following the formula is sort of
implicit in this work of here tomorrow
are you asking about an efficient sort
of like a diff different cannulae don't
know but did you have did you have
interesting adversary structures going
out of you this particular of the
digiorno yeah the different access
structures but still with logarithmic
depth formula so I didn't think about it
uh i think that i'm not sure but i think
for general adversary structures you
couldn't hope to get a logarithmic adapt
and then I didn't think about it too
much but uh I don't feel I can get a
lick but yeah yeah and like food chains
so I have a question about the balanced
approach which it didn't work out 24 is
there hope that it might work 45 or 46
or some like other constant for which I
think we tried that and like the direct
the directing of like a recursive
threshold bukas of threshold gates it
gives you a threshold kind of a
threshold but they're not the threshold
that you would want
so you get any advantage to you can if
you always expand out I mean you will
the formula so each player is
responsible for me one little kind of
things so do we get any advantage if you
get like Eleanor surface using a circuit
to a lockstep circuit you can't you can
transfer into a lock that formula like a
complexity la quinta communications yeah
I'm not sure most